necessity of its removal and the need
for future cooperation of the two
countries and the consent that day Tony
issue of the boundaries would be
resolved following their liberation from
communism but and Soviet imperialism by
freely elected governments of the two
countries and obviously no action for
other you gain and political centers
which operated in the immigration or
diaspora did not to the best of my
knowledge engage in active relations
with polish counterparts but we should
bring an interaction took place on the
level of political conceptualization
scholarship culture foremost in the
press and journals scholarly conferences
joint publications and for formation of
small Ukrainian fully polished societies
and discussion groups in Western Europe
and on the American continent the first
significant impulse for the
normalization of polish italian
relations following the bloody and
brutal events which were described by
colleagues new in chaparral came from
the paris-based polish man c equal to ax
and the public and the publication and
the pies instituted a ski and that the
editorship of the other of years ago
birds and his principal political
publicists urea smear chefs educators
with credentials included at the
editorship of two interesting pre-war
publications boond modic política
formulated a political program which
already in the 1950s and early 1970s
among others improved the recognition of
the existing borders of 1945 to the need
for a close you payin for
nation three polish support when an
independent ukraine lithuania and
dealers the program was received among
the majority of the polish émigré
community with considerable
consternation and or even open ridicule
only okay inside it was acknowledged by
many was also with suspicion as a trick
by the pion to soft light of the younger
generation were attempted to you to take
the ukrainian cause under polish pattern
nevertheless generator spragga attracted
the attention of several dozen respected
ukrainian scholars intellectuals and
publicists and gained him in the 1960s
and between 1960s and 1990s
approximately to have that ukrainian
subscriber puto apaga was opposed by a
variety of east european nationals
including ukrainian and polish for
example of the undead see a variety it
must be pointed out that the other is a
mirror cesky were not anti Russian on
the contrary they believe that the
stable Democratic National Russian state
was in the interest of the other is
Central European countries after
nineteen sixties gather its favored a
two-track approach towered Poland
Ukraine and Russia as well as other East
European countries and the communist
rule and low and and also through
official exchange channels and
unofficially wherever it was possible
the future political elites and
governance could not be at ease could
not be exported from the immigration to
their homeland but that he will emerge
after a successful and hopefully
hopefully peaceful change of regimes
from local party opposition elites and
in this respect he was close to the
tradition of political thinking of the
crack of conservative school and its you
gain and thumbs up our VHS wahoo
Pinsky and ethnic PO but the political
Ukrainian stinka who by the way has
received recently much attention the
representatives of this tradition
maintain that a successful fundamental
change of regimes could occur only if a
significant part of the old early would
side with the Newton's for political
order I have the privilege to know years
together it's personally for 45 years
and in many ways he was a political
visionary and the realist at the same
time and if I had to select the same
most important parts of the 20th century
it would be the Pope for John Paul the
second use a few silky and years again
however among his greatest contributions
was not only his editorial and
publishing activities 630-7 issues of
cultura hundred forty plus issues of
this is